God tells Abraham that he has to take care of his family,
his children.
Now the question is exactly how do you take care of your children?
And the answer is sometimes you make decisions for them.
Now you might say,
well,
it'd be better if they could make the decisions for themselves.
And that's actually the case.
So you might say,
well,
I won't bring my kids to church because it'd be better if they could make the
decision for themselves.
And that's what I did with my kids,
you know,
but I'm not so sure that was a good idea.
And the reason I'm not so sure it was a good idea was because there are a bunch
of things they didn't learn.
Now the degree to which a parents should exercise control over his or her child
is in determinant.
But I guess the hope is that you exercise the minimum amount of control
necessary to maximize the child's probability of success.
And that certainly requires adopting responsibility for making decisions as
well.
Because the child can't make decisions.
You know,
you can't just let the child lay there and make decisions.
Right.
There's,
that's just not going to happen.
And so you might say,
well,
Abraham has no right to impose something like circumcision on his children.
And because they and,
and because it's a sacrifice.
It's something that they should be doing themselves.
But the problem with that is that Abraham also has no right to abdicate his
responsibility to his children in the name of some hypothetical merciful
illness.
And those two things have to be balanced.
Well,
this,
according to the story,
Abraham got the balance right,
because of course he's made this covenant with God now exactly what that means
in people's day to day lives.
Well,
that's a harder issue.
But I would say,
I think in the modern world,
people err on the side of,
I dunno,
I think they're more likely to err on the side of taking insufficient
responsibility for their children,
letting them be free in ways that aren't productive.
That's how it looks to me often because they're afraid of their children.